senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
has been an outspoken critic of
president biden's afghanistan evacuation
calling it a quote botched exit the
senate minority leader joins us now
senator mcconnell thanks for being here
glad to be here brett what are your
thoughts you saw the president's speech
yesterday you've seen the
administration's efforts to talk about
how they said they were prepared for
every contingency and you've seen the
images coming out of the kabul airport
well first let's talk about the decision
to withdraw itself
we were spending about 1 percent of the
pentagon budget every year
to keep the lid on in afghanistan
we hadn't lost a single american soldier
in combat
in the last year
it was working it was working because we
went there
we went there to prevent al qaeda from
being
back in
full operational mode under the taliban
and to sort of keep the lid on my guess
is we're going to end up spending way
more
uh trying to evacuate
people with this slipshod operation
it's an embarrassment sustain on our
national reputation they're up to 15 000
americans stranded out in the country
who presumably have to beg the taliban
to let them get to the airport not to
mention
the interpreters who worked with us
and other afghans who were in danger
because they cooperated with us all of
this is the aftermath
of the decision first to withdraw and
then to withdraw in a precipitous and
incompetent way
i want to get to that decision to
withdraw because obviously the trump
administration was in the same place but
has this administration the body
administration been forthcoming with
briefings
to congress about what's happening now
were they forthcoming with briefings
about their planning on what was going
to happen
yeah well look this was entirely
predictable
i for one along with others have been
predicting this is exactly what would
happen
uh the only question was how quickly
would it happen and i'm frankly not
surprised
uh that there's a total collapse when we
left our european allies left remember
this was a nato mission we weren't there
alone a nato mission
when we left our european allies left
the president immediately said we're
leaving quickly
the afghan military knew at that point
they were on their own
and so we are back to where we were
back to where we were prior
uh to 2011
prior to
2001
and the 2011 attack yeah
senator
here's the president talking about how
he believed that enemies would want us
to have stayed in afghanistan and he
stick sticks by this decision take a
listen
afghanistan is unable to mount any real
resistance of the taliban now
there is no chance
that one year
one more year five more years or 20 more
years u.s military boots on the ground
would have made any difference our true
strategic competitors
china and russia
would love nothing more than the united
states to continue to funnel billions of
dollars in resources and attention and
destabilizing afghanistan indefinitely
how do you respond to that
well one thing we know for sure the
terrorists around the world are cheering
uh they're cheering the terrorists in
syria
in iraq in yemen in africa they're all
watching the taliban flag fly over the
capital
in afghanistan
over the presidential palace in kabul
the taliban has in effect in their eyes
defeated the united states of america
it's an utter
embarrassment
our allies won't trust us
this was a
an incredibly
incompetent step
and i must say previous presidents have
wanted to leave afghanistan as well but
in the end they didn't
because we knew we had the lid on we
knew we had held al qaeda down
and
that's the most we could have hoped for
in afghanistan nobody thought we were
going to create
a jeffersonian western-style democracy
there
yeah but president trump definitely in
his term wanted to get all american
troops home
it wasn't clear how exactly his exit was
going to happen
other than they were trying to negotiate
for something different than what we saw
the other day if you take a look at this
map where you see the taliban movement
over time it's pretty amazing what
happened really in the past 96 hours
for the taliban movement and the new
york times is saying that
the intel was being presented saying
that it was clear evidence of a collapse
of afghan forces after american
officials decided to move out
of
the 2500
what would the trump administration what
would republi republicans have done
differently
if you were going to move those troops
out
well first as i said i wouldn't have
left i think
the policy we were pursuing was working
if you were going to leave at least you
have to have a game plan to try to
rescue the people who are endangered by
these barbarians who are now in charge
of this country do you have any
constituents in there that requires that
it requires a lot more planning look
these guys couldn't organize a two-car
funeral i mean i can't imagine
any
there was no plan at all and you could
see it coming
they had plenty of time to at least plan
an evacuation that had a chance to be
successful so far
this evacuation has failed
should the president be asking for
resignations or
from his national security team
look i mean the president can decide who
works for him it was his decision
he owned it it was a mistake of major
major proportions
are any of your constituents in
afghanistan now
i'm sorry any of your constituents in
afghanistan from kentucky
i'm sorry i couldn't hear you brad i'm
just saying do you know of anybody on
the ground in afghanistan trying to get
out
are people reaching out to your office
i've heard anecdotally that some
some senators and congressmen are are
trying to help individually even though
the administration is saying we're
negotiating with the taliban to let them
into the airport
yeah we've heard from uh people in
kentucky who have
relatives over there who are very much
concerned
about whether they're going to get out
so there's
remember there are up to 15 000
americans out in the country
clamoring to get to the airport and
their relatives all over america are
quite concerned about their safety
and i just want to ask you one thing on
the process going forward on the other
side of the big issue which is the
infrastructure bill and what's going to
happen with speaker pelosi putting
forward this big 3.5
trillion dollar package as you see it
what's going to happen
well of course i'm hoping the 3.5 to 5
trillion dollar tax increase is going to
be defeated that will be determined
within the democratic party every single
republican in the house and senate
is totally opposed to it
just go back to february of 2020 we had
the best economy in 50 years and a big
reason for that
was the 2017 tax bill
they want to take that and rip it up
and raise taxes on big businesses small
businesses
estates of hard-working
people who make
much less than 400 000 a year
it's a devastating blow to the economy
on top of the inflation
we already have
created by the big spending spree that
they engaged in earlier this year so i
think they're clearly trying to take the
country in the wrong direction
senator mcconnell we appreciate your
time
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else